thierry coville chercheur à l'institut
de relations internationales et
stratégiques et spécialiste de l'iran
bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors il ya encore
quelques jours la ie a dénoncé le manque
de coopération de l'iran aujourd'hui un
accord a été trouvé et ce que vous êtes
surpris
pas vraiment parce que c'est quand même
un élément vital si jamais l'iran avait
refusé aux inspecteurs de l'aiea de
venir
regarder ce qui se passait à travers les
caméras etc on pouvait dire que l'accord
de 2015 n'hésitez plus donc c'est bien
la tactique de l'iran à y sait vraiment
quand ils peuvent pas faire autrement et
c'est positif c'est à dire que voilà il
accepte que les yeux un coût continue en
quelque part à contrôler le prendre
nucléaire iranien ça veut dire que
l'accord 2015 est toujours valable
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
quel va être donc l'enjeu de cette
intervention des inspecteurs de l'aiea
sur cet équipement
c'est assez simple
l'iran a signé le traité de non
prolifération
les rendant plus normalement et
l'organisme des nations unies qui doit
contrôler ce traité c'est l'agent satin
siens l'énergie atomique dans le cas des
rangs c'est encore plus important ce
depuis l'acord 2015 c'est là qu'ils
doivent vérifier la bonne application de
l'accord 2015 et que vous l'a expliqué
dans notre reportage en 2015 et l'iran
avaient drastiquement réduit la portée
de son programme nucléaire pour qu'on
soit sûr que le programme ne devienne
pas militaire et donc c'est les
inspecteurs les y aura donc c'est très
important qui à travers leurs caméras
leurs visites régulières des premières
années un certifié que l'iran respecté
ses obligations
depuis la mi-2010 9 c'est de plus en
plus compliqué parce que l'iran est
progressivement sortis de toutes ses
obligations qu'ils avaient qu'elle
s'était engagée en 2015 et je veux dire
le fils qui maintient cet accord de
mekin c'est le fait que la loi puisse
toujours quelque part inspecté ce qui se
passe dans le problème nucléaire iranien
d'où l'importance de cet accord qui
vient d'intervenir est-ce qu'il peut y
avoir d'autres conséquences est ce qu'on
peut peut-être imaginer que l'accord de
vienne puisse ressusciter entre
guillemets c'est justement la deuxième
étape à partir du moment ou quelque part
le lien entre la loire et l'iran il est
toujours respectée on peut dire que
l'accord 2015 il est toujours valable
donc dans ces cas là toute la prochaine
étape c'est effectivement que les
etats-unis l'iran recommencent à
négocier avec les autres signataires de
l'accord pour que les états unis
reviennent dans la corde 2015 et vous
pensez que les états unis vont pouvoir
revenir dans cet accord où ça reste
encore et aux pistes
coûté si l'on recommence ça fait quand
même plusieurs mois que les états unis
on est en déjà négocié un à vienne avec
les
comment dire les cinq autres signataires
de l'accord dont l'iran pour revenir un
accord donc il avait déjà commencé à
négocier et s'ils sont venus à vienne
négocier sur ce sujet c'est qu'ils
veulent ils sont d'accord pour revenir
dans l'accord joe biden je vous rappelle
avait avait annoncé dans sa campagne
électorale dont il tient ses promesses
la grande difficulté c'est que chacun
essaye d'avoir le maximum les rangs veut
que les états unis lèvent le maximum de
sanction qu'ils ont ré imposée à partir
de 2018 et du côté des états unis et
veulent être sûrs que l'iran revienne
dans de toutes ces obligations qui
définissent l accord le 2015 hawks et
c'est un rapport de force et c'est
encore plus vrai avec ce nouveau
gouvernement iranien qui ne jurent que
par le rapport de force avec cet accord
est ce qu'on peut s'attendre à un
apaisement entre l'iran et les autres
ces relations à l'international avec les
autres pays dont les états unis la
évidemment tout est basé à mon avis la
clef de tout c'est cet accord 2015 donc
je crois que c'est dans quelques
semaines les négociations vont reprendre
à vienne donc entre tous les signataires
de l'accord dont les états unis et
l'iran jeu comme vous comme vous l'avez
dit on à un nouveau gouvernement en iran
qui est quand même beaucoup moins pro
occidental que le précédent qu'est book
qui pendent et qui qui veut vraiment
négocier très durement mais d'un autre
côté on sent bien aussi que les radicaux
en iran qui ont tiré à boulet rouge sur
cet accord maintenant ils disent il a
été signé pour le respecter donc on sent
bien aussi qu'il ya une volonté en iran
si toutes les sanctions économiques sont
levés de revenir dans la or du côté
américain il aimerait bien régler ce
problème là pour au moins diminuer les
tensions avec les rangs d'avis et la clé
des relations de l'iran avec le reste du
monde cet accord de sur l'éclair dans
les états unis l'ont bien compris donc
je pense qu'il y à il ya une volonté
d'aboutir à un accord du côté iranien et
américain alors ensuite qu'est ce que ça
va donner dans les négociations
chaque sous l'ailé du côté iranien
notamment ils vont ils veulent plus
faire de concession donc les
négociations pourraient être dur mais
disons bon on veut dire on sent une
envie quand même du côté iranien côté
américain d'aboutir à un accord merci
beaucoup pour votre analyse thierry
coville je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur à l'institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques et
spécialiste de l'iran merci à vous